nouveau procès pour le président de la
région catalane king torah il s'agit de
son deuxième pour délits présumés de
désobéissance
alors les faits remontent à septembre
2019 en pleine campagne électorale pour
les élections nationales espagnoles
le président avait refusé de retirer une
pancarte affichée sur le siège de la
catalogne situé à barcelone
cette pancarte affichée un ruban jaune
indépendantiste en soutien aux hommes
politiques indépendantistes catalans
incarcéré pour tentative de sécession en
alors pour ce procès actuel kim torah a
choisi d'opter pour son droit au silence
il a même déclaré à la sortie du
tribunal que de toute façon le tribunal
n'était pas neutre selon ses propres
mots alors concernant son premier procès
il faut se souvenir que c'était aussi
pour délits présumés de désobéissance
qui ne t'aura avait aussi refusé de
retirer un ruban jaune affiché sur le
siège de la catalogne alors il a été
condamné en décembre dernier à une peine
d'inégibilité de 18 mois mais kim torah
a fait appel auprès du tribunal suprême
l'équivalent de la cour de cassation
alors la destitution tu n'as pas été
appliquée mais la sentence pourrait être
connu dans les prochains jours il s'agit
d'un calendrier délicat puisque la date
d'anniversaire du référendum
indépendantiste approche mais aussi
stèle des émeutes de l'an dernier